I want to talk about Captain Marvel for
a second because the Disney Japan
website revealed this week the Captain
Marvel will be set in 1995 we knew would
be the night a year that was announced
but now this is the first time we're
having a there's the first time we
haven't I got a fiscal year this works
with a lot of fumes that we've seen in
the trailer like Carol Danvers crashes
through even one monster video not a
blockbuster and that rebrand actually
took place in 1996 since Anna you see a
map at the LA Green Line subway which
fits because that opened in 1995 as well
she's matching that green line with that
green outfit but things are pointing out
that all of the Rock the Vote signs that
we're actually from 1992 and if you zoom
in enhance you can see that underneath
those posters are some flyers for a pig
fart show I am unfamiliar with that band
but it's for a show on Thursday August
29th and August 29th fell on a Thursday
in 1991 and 1996 so what you guys send
in it may be that they're old only thing
is obviously The Rock the Vote posters
don't look but also this could just be
an advance notice for a show taking
place for the following year you know
you want to get um some hype or the rock
the boat should be for the next year you
know you start getting the word out and
during the primary seasons in 95 so
that's a big in 95 across the Marvel
Universe stuff is going on okay so the
Starks are dead that was 91 95 would be
I think that's a year where Thanos
conquered gomorrah's home planet with
our world thank you for the fun fact
that we learned that was the year that
Bill Clinton confirmed that area 51 is a
real place so maybe that lines up with
the alien crash landing in our world
yeah honestly so if you don't know the
area 51 story right like famously in the
50s supposedly there was a crash landing
and then you know area 51 like I guess
is where that remains that crash landing
our if for some reason a second alien
crash landing or something is the reason
that barry 51 existed harder to hide
when something crash lands in a
blockbuster video tougher yeah anyway
and maybe that's why they they were just
propped up by the government the
government did know to keep up with
competition like red box and netflix and
that's
crash also in our world the OJ Simpson
verdict oh yeah that's it what she's
huge
that that hopefully will at least get
reference at some point she's got to put
in some gloves and they don't fit right
you know wait for me okay I think that
Bill Clinton area 51 I think that might
be the easiest really the most
fascinating because we're talking about
like a Secret Invasion potentially right
that's the story of the scroll you know
feeling anxiety and imposing its people
yeah I mean there's also very decent
chance that they're not gonna reference
know yeah and they were just like no it
took place you know in the 90s and we
want in nineties in what should be to
counter that it would have been more
significant for this movie to do it I
feel like for fans in 1998 so that it
was there was a ten-year gap between the
first Iron Man movie and then this and I
feel like the events of those I feel
like it would've been a cool mirror
image of like okay moving forward
Black Panther Captain Marvel and doctor
changes the name they always start over
spider-man being like our new three or
four that we want to push and I feel
like if you wanted to make it more
significant you would've picked a date
like that so 95 has more significance
with this area 51 comment what about
Captain Marvel sequels would they want
to do the kind of Wonder Woman thing
where it still keeps taking place in the
past we've always assumed at the end of
Captain Marvel will end with her getting
sent out in space when there's like you
know whatever reason that she's not
available now but maybe she is still
around in 96 and in 97 and in 98 or do
you think that they're gonna set Captain
Marvel sequels post infinity war like
they'll catch up the way they did with
like Captain America and then it ends
with him in the present day I think I
would I would prefer that honest me to
it'll be fun
but what if Avengers four we've talked
about so many different theories of
Avengers for what if it just takes place
removed from time in space and logic and
then so like yes she could still fight
along with them in the present day sort
of and another reality but then may be
of interest for ends with everyone just
going back to where they came from or
back from the time they came back to
when they came from including Captain
America including Captain Marvel
somebody so and essentially you're just
dropping a theory they're right that the
that her role is more because of the
time stone that that she's able to take
place in this and they're different
realities too like this is so many
different ways this could go for sure
but also I do want to go back to that
idea of Danos
you know doing what he did on commercial
yeah because did that like sense some
kind of like blip on the radar like did
shield start leaving their activities
when they're like oh there's this mad
Titan or were they completely blind I
thought exactly because she's part of an
intergalactic they call it space this is
not space force but they call it was
start star force that's what it was
star force and so they they could be
more like the Green Lantern's where
they're going out and they're like
taking care of other planets as well or
maybe they're not and they get word of
this and they go out and they start
sending out scouts of like oh this
person's like having the populations of
planets like we have to do something she
gets a knock on the noggin and she's out
well do we know how long ago that OSes
plan started we don't we what's weird
because he already had the mine stone
and we don't know the story of how we
got that mines does it cuz say you know
gamora's home planet was a pilot run of
like you know doing this whatever and
then he's like he does that and then
it's essentially out there he's going to
every plan and he's gonna do a version
of this if he can't get the stones he's
just gonna go planet by planet return to
your home planets and go protect your
home planet maybe there'll be some kind
of Captain Marvel movie maybe this one
or some future one that ends with the
Kree fighting the news and our battles
prevent Thanos from getting the Power
Stone it's a story that we know happen
but we didn't see it go down and you
know I kind of want to see Xander gets
destroyed it happens all the time
only kind of makes all the time they
don't care about that oh no defense yeah
so I want to see that battle you want to
see how he got it why do you think she
doesn't have a memory and you said that
he has the mind stone so that would be
kind of interesting to see the my son
being you cuz he doesn't use it movie
besides yeah all over the same time he
was kicked in the head with a marbles
part we're like oh we're watching
Captain Marvel and it's so disconnected
from infinity war and yet she's about to
be so essential in infinity war part two
if Thanos makes a cameo yeah that would
be a great idea unbeliev airy smart I
feel like that'd be a very smart move
and it also doesn't have to you can
still watch that movie and just
understand that this is a person that's
going to be a threat in a future Martin
Captain Marvel happy and it doesn't it
doesn't you know it doesn't you don't
need to know anything going yeah he
doesn't have to be like from his whole
storyline he could be just like you know
hanging out on earth like getting
commercial work or whatever
yeah great advice
he's like a jazz player you're like the
after shot after grimace stopped eating
McDonald's yeah what you could be well
let us know in the comments down below
wait your theories are for why Captain
Marvel needs to take place in the
nineties they put it there in it for a
reason do you think we hid it somewhere
this conversation or do you have some
other ideas but as always subscribe to
new rock stars for all of our deep dives
into all the Avengers news you need to
know about